[Music]
this is what the nfl is pushing because
they feel the cultural momentum
from the left what they don't understand
is sooner or later there's going to be a
backlash and it's going to be quite ugly
against a lot of the same institutions
that have been renormalized on behalf of
radicals
you want to know why exactly there are
people in florida who are worried about
social issues in l.a it's because they
know that california would like to
extend the dominance of this ideology
into florida
and so for example this is a a locker
room
controversy at a spa in l.a in los
angeles
uh there's a los angeles spa it's called
the wii spa
and an outraged woman in a biological
woman
who happens to be minority apparently
she walks up to the desk and she says
i'm in there with young little girls in
the spa and there's a man walking around
with his junk hanging out
and the spot insists that this is no
problem because of course the man
identifies as a woman here's a little
bit of the video
i just want to be clear with you it's
okay
it's okay for a man to go into the
women's section
show his penis around the other women
young little girls under age
your spa we spa condone that is that
what you're saying
like i asked it's so he he could stay
there
he could stay there what sexual
orientation i see
it lets me know he's a man he he's a man
okay but there's an entire wing of
american public life that says not only
is he not a man this woman is a bigot
for saying that a man walking around a
spa with his junk hanging out
is a woman right if you say that that
that
man is not a woman you are the bigot
she's the bigot
i mean these are social issues that have
dramatic ramifications because it is
coming for you it is coming for your
business it is coming for your religious
life it is coming for your school
the left has made this absolutely
apparent and not just
on the governmental level right using
anti-discrimination laws in order to
cram down this bizarre version
of human logic in which men can become
women and women can become
men an unprecedented notion in all of
human logic or history or biology or
physics
or any other field of human endeavor it
is institutions
who have socially taken up the cause
because they understand that the left is
pushing for control
and the right has been back footed on
this stuff they've been wrong-footed for
years and years and years the right has
been told you know why are you focusing
on those social issues if you just leave
the social issues off the table because
that's the contentious stuff
then focusing on economics that's where
you guys are going to win you're going
to win supporters when it comes to lower
taxes and lower spending
it is precisely the opposite if you look
at the trump coalition the trump
coalition was largely rooted in cultural
concerns
not in economic concerns and those
cultural concerns
grow more grave every single day because
there is one group that is on the march
and one group that simply seeks to
preserve
its own perspective on life which
happens to be rooted in reality and
biology and natural law
again people on the right are not making
the case per se
that a private business in los angeles
doesn't have the ability
to have single sex locker rooms they're
saying you don't get to leverage that
idea on me
the left has no such limitations on its
own ambitions here
and the cultural institutions of our day
are seeking to cram down values that
have literally nothing to do
with their core businesses on everybody
else remember
we don't just live in a governmental
sphere or laws and regulations live in a
cultural sphere
so it does make a difference what your
kids watch on tv it does make a
difference what major corporations
are attempting to leverage down on your
kids when you walk into a target
and fruitloops is selling gay pride
month
paraphernalia to your five-year-old
right and that's what it's directed at
well that has an impact on how your kid
thinks and to pretend that it doesn't
is to ignore what time it is it is to
ignore what is going on in the world
okay the this is why parents are
attempting to guard their children it's
why parents are saying
you know we just want to be left alone
but you will not leave us alone
and by the way if forced to it if forced
to the confrontation the cold civil war
that is currently happening
will continue to heat up there will just
be a struggle for who gets
to control everybody else there will not
be any broad-based agreement on
classical liberalism where you get to do
what
what you want to do and i get to do what
i want to do if the left push is too
hard they're not going to get classical
liberals in response
they're going to get people on the right
who react by saying okay well we will
take
control of the commanding heights and
now we will use our leverage to press
our own political viewpoint into law
we will attempt to cram down on you what
it is that we want
not even on a state or local level we
want
and not even with regard to public
funded enterprise we'll do with regard
to private funded enterprise
they are the left's radicalism and and
deep
willingness to renormalize institutions
to weaponize against people they don't
like
is going to result in a backlash that is
going to be far uglier than what the
left thinks is going to happen next
and it does come down to things like
what you see in your daily life pissing
you off right it does come down to
things like the nfl for example
putting out full-scale commercials
saying football is gay okay now let's be
real about this football is football
it's not gay it's not straight football
is just football
the hell does the nfl have to say about
sexual politics when you turn on a game
typically it's because you wish to watch
people play football not because you
wish to watch the nfl
socially message about any particular
social issue whether you're talking
about hands up don't shoot which was a
lie or whether you're talking about
homosexuality and politics
and yet this is what the nfl is pushing
because they feel the cultural momentum
from the left what they don't understand
is sooner or later there's going to be a
backlash and it's going to be quite ugly
against a lot of the same institutions
that have been renormalized on behalf of
radicals
most americans have been apathetic about
these sorts of issues the harder the
left pushes the more the backlash is
going to be
the greater the backlash is the more
polarized the country becomes
there is no apathetic middle anymore you
will not be allowed to be apathetic
you will not be allowed to say things
like i don't care what the nfl sexual
politics is i just want to watch
football
that in and of itself will be evident of
your discriminatory nature
here's the nfl ad
it says football is gay
interesting football is lesbian football
is beautiful football is queer it's
life's exciting it's transgender it's
bisexual
football is freedom football is american
football is accepting
football is everything well it isn't
football is everything for everyone
except
if you happen not to believe in the
morality of particular sexual behavior
if you believe in traditional natural
law morality with regard to sac football
is apparently not for you
if you believe in going to church and
you actually read the bible apparently
football is not for you
when they say football is for everyone
they mean everyone will be forced to
agree with us and then football will be
for everyone
in the same way that joe biden suggested
that he was going to pursue a new unity
and i said at the time does he mean
unity
while acknowledging the the possibility
that people disagree with him or does he
mean unity and that he is going to cram
down a unified agenda on everyone
regardless of whether they agree and it
became pretty obvious pretty clearly
and pretty fast that he meant the latter
right okay and you can see it all of
this is manifesting in every area of
american life simultaneously
every area of american life has become
polarized in our new cold civil war
the battle for the culture is heating up
we here at the daily wire are making
some big moves so be sure to like
subscribe ring that bell because you're
not going to want to miss a single
moment